all I got is my degree you know people
say get your degree but then they don't
talk about how you need experience the
degree was the
experience I need relax Allison has a
degree in business marketing and this is
not a metaphorical degree she tells us
it is a literal degree a literal whole
ass degree as she might say uh she
currently has a job as a waitress which
she effing hates and she wants to land a
position in her chosen field but the
problem is that all the jobs she can get
would uh would pay her less than she
makes as a waitress she's been applying
to jobs for effing weeks now but all the
positions that pay big money 150 200k
she can't get because she doesn't have
experience plus as she says she's
competing against corporate ass America
but she feels that it's unfair because
she feels she does have experience as
the degree was the experience she says
let's uh sort through this never
publicly complain about your job I say
it again never publicly complain about
your job it is never a good idea to
declare to the world that you effing
hate your job